let's get into audience questions for
the week first one is hey david is being
against
immigration necessarily racist couldn't
you simply be against immigration but
not for racist or xenophobic reasons
yeah i mean listen this is i prefer to
deal in reality rather than in than
in hypotheticals of course it's possible
that you might be someone who
does not care about race or ethnicity
you're against immigration to the united
states
from any country for any reason
whatsoever doesn't matter if it's a
country of predominantly white or brown
people
or if it's a predominantly richer poor
country sure that that exists
the reality is that um in in
uh of vast uh swaths of situations
the economic arguments that you often
hear made against immigration
really only end up applying to
or people are only thinking of those
from countries where the immigrants are
more brown or black
than they are white um and we see this
in a number of different ways which
we'll talk about
um you can for sure i mean listen
first of all there are studies that show
that racism and anti-immigrant sentiment
are highly
correlated now you could be racist
and against immigration for other
reasons that are not related to
race or ethnicity sure that that's quite
possible
but decades of data show us that
preconceived prejudicial notions about
wraith and
race and ethnicity tend to correlate
with
anti-immigrant sentiment now there are
many
economic questions about immigration
that can be made we've analyzed many of
them like for example
immigrants are taking the jobs of
americans
immigrants reduce wages immigrants
are leeching off of the system and every
single one of these has
an answer and it's typically not what
the anti-immigration crowd
says one of the things i think is useful
when you're dealing with someone
who claims to be just against
immigration
period is to talk about a situation
in which the immigrants are
uh typically white from so-called
western age
nations and gauge the reaction to that
situation and then talk about immigrants
from countries where people tend to be
brown or black
or at least the belief is when you talk
about immigrants from
mexico or haiti the people aren't white
and see if you get the same reaction i
mean
it's it's you know we can study these
things scientifically
and empirically and it's been done but
when when you have such a situation if
it's someone you know
gauge their reaction talk about
immigrants from norway and sweden
and then talk about immigrants from from
haiti or mexico whatever whatever the
case may be now they may say well there
i have a different opinion about
immigrants from sweden
versus immigrants from haiti but it's
not because of race
it's because it's about skill and i
believe
that for no racially uh uh motivated
reason
the people coming from sweden are higher
skilled
than the pers than the people coming
from haiti
the reality is that there's plenty of
highly skilled
computer programmers engineers
people in the medical field you know
accountants coming from
africa some of the top
engineering and programming people that
i know in the united states
are from argentina now there's an
availability bias for sure
me being from argentina i just know more
argentinians also argentina's mostly
white but
a lot of racists don't realize that they
don't know the difference between
argentina
and mexico and you know costa rica or
whatever the case may be
uh but this is you know i'm reminded of
the situation with the israeli bds
movement where
in principle just saying for political
reasons israel should be boycotted
that's not anti-semitic but the bds
movement
is a haven for and provides cover for
many anti-semites whose reasons stated
for boycotting israel could apply to 10
other countries
which they either aren't even aware of
or are aware of but certainly aren't
interested or advocating in
in boycotting so yes you can be i mean
if you're just trying to get me to say
you can be against immigration and not
be a racist of course
of course now that we've gotten back
beyond the hypothetical
let's actually deal with the typical
reasons that are given for being against
immigration and see if they're applied
equally
uh regardless of of race or ethnicity
and you very quickly see how
it is a cover for lots of racists and
xenophobes
you may not have known this but when you
see me sitting here on the show
i am often wearing shirts by a company
called teddy stratford i asked them to
be a sponsor because they are by far
my favorite shirts that i own with
almost
all other slim fit button up shirts i've
worn
you get this annoying stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are which
does not look good
but what makes teddy stratford shirts
unique is this patented zipper that's
hidden
underneath the buttons which actually
prevents the chest from looking weird
and stretched out like that
it looks really good and just all around
they cut the entire shirt in a specific
way
that makes your upper body look a lot
better it's just a much nicer and more
stylish fit
than you get from other shirts and they
hand make everything with 100
egyptian cotton and flat felled seams
which means it's going to be a lot more
durable
than other shirts and last a lot longer
which i really love
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout